there is something in the water of a
small Tennessee town that helped
revitalize its struggling economy people
look to their leg to build the tourism
industry from scratch the bass in the
lake help bring 14 million dollars to
the town of Dayton Tennessee in just one
year Dana Jacobson is here with now with
the focus on how fishing became a
lucrative lifeline Dana good morning
good morning a small town in Tennessee
was looking for ways to boost its
economy they realized the solution might
actually be right in front of them in
the form of a lake all they needed to do
was lure in fishermen to become a sports
tourism destination on a cool Thursday
morning before sunrise nearly 200 bass
fishing boats launched from a small dock
in Dayton Tennessee while the anglers
compete to hook the biggest bass in
Chickamauga Lake the town is cashing in
so says Dennis Tomlin the head of the
county's economic and Tourism Council
how much money has fishing brought to
your community of date our statistics
show us that about fourteen million new
dollars came into town last year
fourteen million dollars and things like
food lodging and new tax revenue that's
a big deal for this small town of 7200
in southeastern Tennessee we now have a
tournament comes in every year with 400
boats mayor gary Llewellyn was raised in
Dayton tell me what Dayton was like when
you were growing up here it was just a
small country town had little country
stores it's also a town that's been
struggling since the recession Dayton is
in the heart of Rhea County it's one of
the more depressed areas of Tennessee
based on statistics that include poverty
rate household income and unemployment I
didn't know it being politics I've been
a businessman all my life but when mayor
Luallen was elected four years ago he
had a plan to turn around
Dayton's economy it started out with the
council I fished and I went to them with
the idea and I said guys if you'll just
trust me and run women-only fishing
could really make a good for us
turns out Dayton was sitting on a secret
Chickamauga lake is more than 50 miles
long and boasts some of the best bass
fishing in the south there you go
awesome
in 2014 the town began sharing their
local treasure using it to reel in
big-time fishing competitions and we
begin to think of this lake as an
opportunity
Tumlin was lured back home from his job
at coca-cola by the opportunity to help
his boyhood town we went after tourism
which the tourism comes in many shapes
forms and fashions for us it happens to
be fishing for other communities it may
be something else it may be horseback
riding but for us it was fishing you
have a number even that one angler will
bring into your community absolutely
industry statistics will tell you that
the average angler spends $1,100 in a
week that they will spend $1,100 in your
community and how many anglers might you
have on a weekend here this particular
tournament has 400 anglers I can't do
that kind of math you know it's
impactful you know one event by itself
is powerful but we've been averaging 30
events per year for the last 30 years
Michael Neal second place with fishermen
their families and fans coming into
Dayton the local service industry has
been booming yeah fishing was obviously
awesome
Nathaniel Eastwood is the general
manager of the sleep in one of two new
lodging facilities that have opened
recently three or four years ago the
nonetheless evander it's like I said
it's a major catalyst for what we've
been able to accomplish and there are
five new restaurants as well
Dayton isn't the only town in the game
you do not need to host the Olympics to
become a sports destination Mary Helen
Sprecher is managing editor of a
magazine dedicated to sports tourism she
points to events like the fat tire bike
race in cable Wisconsin and on they go
fifty three kilometers down the American
Birkebeiner ski race in nearby Hayward
Wisconsin and especially the pickleball
tournament in Naples Florida as success
stories they were planning on maybe a
five hundred thousand dollar economic
impact they had one point five million
dollars in economic in pain one year in
one event for all the money that sports
can bring in Denis Tomlin says the
tournaments are just a first step
towards a larger goal what about the
idea of industry growing from this might
you see that - absolutely so industry
we're chasing industry as hard as worth
chasing tourism if you're an industry
CEO you're looking for quality of life
so when you come here we want you to
feel energy and and feel a great
community and we believe it will yield
great results a little foreshadowing
there just days after we visited Tumlin
announced that Dayton had reeled in a
big fish if you will a Finnish company
no key and tires announced a 360 million
dollar investment in a new plant in
Dayton along with the promise of 400 new
jobs and again this is a small town yeah
so this has a huge impact on them great
catch no release yes but they were catch
and release on the fish Dana thanks as
always